foreign
[Music]
first of all thank you so much for
attending today's talk and I would like
to discuss on how to get started
building apps on app sheet so first and
foremost a bit about myself I am sujata
dusi I am a customer engineering lead
for Google workspace for India and I've
been working along with several
customers across the country on helping
them in their modernization Journey
transformation journey and also looking
at in this discussion about how
organizations can also build no code
applications for their environment to
help automate several processes within
their setup
so that said uh let's quickly dive into
the actual topic
so first and foremost what is app sheet
app sheet is Google Cloud's no code app
development platform so that immediately
allows you to create applications that
do Enterprise grade applications
including automations by leveraging app
sheet so customers can digitize their
workflows can help automate any of their
business needs and get things done
faster smarter now why is it important
now
so there are several trends that we have
been working on studying through and
that is where we have seen why this is a
need of the r and more and more
Enterprises needed across different
Industries to build applications easily
for them as organizations
now the first Trend that we look at
is
we have done several analysis and
surveys with CEOs and cxos of
organizations and what we have seen is
75 percent of organizations
are looking at prioritization
and prioritizing their transformation
Journey
so that's the key here so whether it is
for their employees knowledge workers or
for their Frontline workers they are
looking at that digital transformation
in their environments
so
another major cue here is there's a huge
shift in Marketplace
so more and more organizations are
uh seeing employees build their own
applications to get their things done so
that is where Shadow I.T is coming into
place because employees are using apps
from Marketplace unapproved apps
services in order to get their things
done faster
and just for a no code application
platform uh Marketplace we see a
predicted growth of almost 23 percent in
just 2021 and over the years ahead so
organizations are investing in giving
the right tools for their employees to
get their work done now that is where
technology plays quite an important role
here and employees are looking for ways
where the processes can be automated can
be improvised but what they typically
see is that they don't have a lot of
options to do that now the first thing
that you see here tracking with pen and
paper several employees field workers
several personas of users still use a
pen and paper to get their work done or
track their work
another major observation is developing
Solutions the time taken to develop new
applications and solutions is becoming
very slow and expensive because they
depend on another team to get it done
and always resort to the I.T in order to
get the right tools for them to finish
their work
now another major Trend here is about
purchasing external Solutions
now once they are not able to develop
they obviously resort to purchasing new
Solutions right and that is where
purchasing is also becoming more
expensive plus Solutions serve very
limited use cases like once you go for
external solutions they go for literally
targeted solutions for one particular
issue but if you need to extend it to
other processes within your environment
that again becomes a challenge
now finally there are one set of users
who use all of these spreadsheets Google
forms and other forms in order to
collect data get things done or build
those automations while it is effective
the data is still dispersed or present
in different places so it is still
getting into that uh how to manage the
inventory or how to manage those
approvals ticketings and there are other
processes which are coming on top of
this process
so these are the four major trends that
we look at so as we move ahead
with app sheet
we have built a no code platform where
any user Persona again it's not just it
from business any Persona can literally
rapidly develop applications and
automate their own processes they don't
need to depend on a separate third party
agency or an I.T team or a developer
ecosystem to build an app
so that is where the whole uh value add
comes in and the best part with app
sheet is that you are not just building
apps for one platform or one device
once you build an application it fits
whether it's a mobile device or a
desktop service
the same app can fit any kind of device
or persona
and finally the center part about
customizing or connecting with your
existing data so app sheet can help
connect with your data where it is
currently so it may be in a sheet it can
be in a database it can be on an sap
system wherever your data is currently
the app connects to the data where it
currently resides
again the database can be a cloud-based
or an on-prem database it can still
connect
so what is appsheet really doing
in a normal application building process
we see situations where there is a
complete life cycle that is a
development life cycle from an idea
which takes few days then it goes into
the actual app building which may take
another few weeks or maybe months and
finally there are code reviews the
development team builds the application
after code reviews there's a two and
fourth there and finally the application
end product comes
now all of this is taking quite a lot of
time
and by that time employees are resorting
to Shadow I.T or other tools just to get
the work done in this meantime
now that is where app sheet helps in
reducing the time for building the
application right from an idea to a
final solution because you are no longer
depending on multiple steps code reviews
I've seen organizations where just code
reviews the security code reviews
penetration testings all of those itself
takes so much time
which is all avoided because the entire
code based system the servers on which
all of this is running is managed by
Google
on app sheet as a platform and all the
users are doing is majorly working on
the idea and the business problem and
how to solve the business problem by
using or building the application
so that's it a typical customer
now workspace is an underlying platform
on top of which app sheet helps with a
lot more Integrations but it doesn't
mean that app sheet cannot work without
workspace but it just adds to that fact
that there are a lot more Integrations
or intuitiness that end users would see
whether it is a dynamic email or other
connections with a sheet
but on top of the all of that we have
seen customers build several
applications to streamline their
processes now in this pandemic I can say
several customers have built app
delivery services field users
particularly the Frontline users can
leverage app sheet to simplify their
work
enter data easily
we have several manufacturing customers
leveraging app sheet for barcode
scanning on their actual manufacturing
unit where every part or a unit can be
scanned and the inventory can be
calculated assessed or understand the
supply input output these are just some
of the examples
some more examples that I can talk of
are now with the return of work or the
hybrid environment that's kicking in
several customers are also building
hotdesting apps temperature check apps
or visitor Management Systems all of
them through app sheet
so with that said app sheet is an
extremely open platform
why we say open is because it is not
stuck with a particular data source that
okay my data has to be in this format no
wherever your data is we integrate with
that data source
again we have worked in order to build
Integrations with several data sources
that are available you can see a list
there are different spreadsheets
available databases most commonly used
databases are all there again this is
not the end list but it's about the art
of possibility for you to understand
that app sheet can integrate with where
your data resides
now
app sheet is also a lot powered by AI
I'll show some of some parts of this in
the demonstration as well where once you
input the data the application is
intelligent enough to understand what is
the data type of this application
what type of input can this app take
what is the view which will fit
and
with app sheet you can also Leverage The
Power of all other services of Google
because it can integrate with maps API
Vision API understand OCR understand
text which is handwritten
so it's about integrating with other
apis and bring in the power of AIML to
your application and your processes
again these are some of the use cases we
have seen across Enterprises uh for
field users the floor users office users
we have seen a wide variety of use cases
these are some of the common ones we
have seen customers in the financial
segment building apps for their
particular offices their different
branch offices so that they can leverage
to input information from customers all
of these applications become those
Central apps which anyone in the
organization can use without any kind of
development effort and the ease of
extensibility of applications
so here are some of the examples but the
art of possibility is really unlimited
because we have seen customers doing a
lot lot more with app sheet
right from project management apps
visitor management apps ticketing
systems being built on app sheet
now that's it
with the no code architecture
now let's try to understand there are
application users Now app sheet is not
necessary to be used by every user in an
organization you can also start small
with a certain business unit where they
have an application requirement and
build apps and then extend it to the
rest of users so identifying those
application users play becomes critical
apart from that how the users access the
application that is where the
authentication model comes in with app
sheet you can integrate with existing
SSO Solutions and help access and
leverage that authentication
authorization setups already available
and finally we speak about how they can
be accessed from any device so
irrespective of whether you are a mobile
user or a desktop laptop user you can
still access the same app and get your
work done
which eases because earlier days I am
sure you've known or seen scenarios
where an app was built only for the web
or an app was a mobile only app and it
would take whole lot of time and effort
just to extend it that the app is
compatible with a particular device but
all of these become not applicable
scenarios in app sheet because once you
build it it gets compatible with any and
every device so that's the beauty in
which the entire workflow or the
architecture flows in and finally you
can integrate with your data sources and
pull in your data for the application
so let's now look at one example this is
an inventory management app which I'll
Showcase in the demonstration where it
has data source or Integrations with
different uh data types like a sheet is
what I will be using for database there
are email templates which I will be
leveraging in order to send automated
emails to end users I'll also be
leveraging calendar and meet integration
so that end users get invites once there
are some triggered actions in order to
block time and all some images are
picked from Drive which is leveraged as
storage but these are only examples you
can literally build from any kind of
data source so I just want to let you
understand the kind of options available
so with that we will now switch to a
demonstration and quickly look at how it
works in action
foreign
I've already pre-built it and I'm now
looking at how the app can be seen
and how the different views of the app
are also available
now first and foremost in an application
there's different information that you
get like the information of the app the
kind of data it is using the ux model
just to understand the view or to
optimize The View based on your
requirement security parameters as to
who has access who cannot access who has
what level of access can all be
controlled and then the automation
segment where you can build Bots and
Trigger items on an application at any
point of time so let's quickly see that
so first and foremost is the data now in
this scenario I've literally created
multiple tables if you see there is a
categories table there's an inventory
table items and vendors table
now if I click on view source
this is the data that I'm currently
leveraging which has items vendors
categories and inventory information
now that said the app is quickly able to
see all that item list the images were
all pre-built from the sheet which had
the data and I can optimize the ux now
let's see this is a line view I want a
more easier view so I can change the
card View
I can brand it based on my organization
templates I can also leverage different
options
so
these are some of the options and
behaviors now in automation segment
again I can build this is something that
I've already created where I notify the
vendor
Whenever there there's an email that is
triggered by any by the app Whenever
there is a entry that is created
so let's now look at the app here
I open it in a separate tab
and I get to see a few full view of the
app
I can create new entries in the
application like
I can enter an image
I can choose a category
add details
fill all the mandatory fields and I
click on Save
so this becomes a item form for your app
itself
now this is these are mandatory details
that have been asked so this is an
example of an app more from an inventory
management
now let's take another quick example
another way to build an app
now this is a simple uh sheet that I've
created here which includes different
columns as you see task status due date
priority and project this is again a
very common example that we see where we
track actions of different tasks that a
user is doing now how easy it is to
build an application out of a sheet
you get into Extinction
and add a app sheet extension to your
app
and just click on create an app
once I do that based on the data in the
sheet
app sheet is automatically building an
app for me
and I can continue and customize the app
in my scenario there are errors from a
schema standpoint I think these are
common errors in live demonstrations
that I can say but this is one other
simple way to build an app
now another final option is there are
other several templates available with
an app sheet which can also be used to
automatically build apps from templates
these are pre-built templates that are
already available you can simply
customize any of the templates and build
it for your environment so we already
saw three ways one is directly from data
directly from a sheet directly from a
template now let's say you are not
worried about all of these but you just
have some idea
you can still do that by clicking on
start with an idea
let's say there's a shop flow
I just click shop flow and I don't have
any idea whatsoever so it's
automatically giving me suggestions that
this is an app for a collection of shop
floors
on top of this what is usually in a shop
floor equipment
so I click on equipment
and
a shop floor has many equipment
now it's automatically building a
relationship based on an idea that I
have
now there's a shop floor there's
equipment on the shop floor now there
are issues
issues in the equipment so user tracks
issues with equipment
now if You observe I was just entering
issues or keywords that I had idea of
but app sheet is automatically giving me
suggestions of what it can look at
now I want to save and refine give a
name
and I click on go
and app sheet is automatically building
an app out of some ideas that I had
now once the app is ready I can then
refine it I can change the ux I can
change the data input the data or also
create all the automations that I was
talking about earlier
so these are some quick queries in which
you can easily build applications for
your setup
let's switch back to the slides once
again in order to see how it can
effectively while the app is built let's
now look at how you can optimize your
data in order to build apps more
effectively or simply now first and
foremost we spoke about how you can use
a sheet for app sheet right but it just
cannot be any random data unrefined data
no you still need a structure to the
data you need to have valid column names
proper names which can signify as to
what that field is
I give a name phone number it
automatically tells me that it will pick
which is where the AI part of the app
sheet comes in where it understands that
okay this is the field for that
particular column in the application so
these are some of the good examples so a
good column name scenario can be this
way like an email a name phone number so
there are some good examples and bad
examples never use symbols all of that
within the column names
similarly data types again it's very
similar to an rdbms where there's a key
you still need to have a primary key and
all of it but it's just that it
understands it automatically and eases
your work
and finally there are also best
practices on how to use keys so that you
can manage the data more effectively
this is a bad example of a sheet that
you can leverage for app sheet but at
the same time I was earlier showing a
more refined sheet which helped me build
the app more easily
so that's it we want all of you to start
your transformation Journey you to build
apps for your setup for your users and
you yourself create it for yourself in
order to optimize your own work and you
can start by leveraging or accessing
appsheet.com
no code is the way to go and thank you
so much for your time and for
understanding app sheet have a nice day
[Music]